Diane is with us in Fresno hi Diane how
are you I'm doing well how are you today
better than I deserve what's up well the
Lord convicted me last week of all my
spending bed spending habits okay
and I have a defaulted student loan and
I was on Social Security disability for
a while so I owe the government money
because I was overpaid and currently my
my job is I I just have been very
unsuccessful trying to find full-time
work I work seasonal full-time for the
IRS and this past year I worked over six
months so I brought in about thirteen
thousand dollars and then I had to wait
until last month in October to start my
unemployment which happens every year
and right now I'm bringing in about one
thousand seventy eighty seven dollars a
month the unemployment how much do you
owe on the back Social Security I
believe it's only eighteen fifty
thirteen thousand okay and how much do
you owe on the defaulted student loan
well I've gotten contacted by two
different places I didn't realize it but
there was a company I guess that was
wanted me to consolidate everything and
they were going to they were saying that
I owned thirty thousand dollars okay all
right so so thirty and thirteen forty
three thousand dollar straightens up
your whole life what is the best income
year you've ever had in your life
when I had a full-time job was right out
of college and I have a bachelor's
degree in social work and I was working
a job for almost a year and I was
earning $14.40 thirteen dollars and
forty cents an hour the best income
you've ever had in two years twenty
thousand dollars a year yeah
and how old are you I'm 53 53 yeah okay
and what was the nature of your
disability I have mental illness and
what my depression depression okay yeah
I mean basically I was taken off of
Social Security disability because they
said I have full-time gainful employment
to die rs are you seeing are you seeing
someone for your depression yes how are
you doing you're getting better I'm
getting a lot better yeah you sound
pretty good yeah I'm doing well all
right okay so cheerful sound in your
voice it's good I was a wreck last week
I was crying so much because I was just
so convicted I listened to your program
like every day and I listen to these
people shouting I'm debt free and it's
like I want to be that person well I
think what we have is is that you've
never experienced success in your career
I have it and that and that is
depressing for folks for anyone
regardless if they're fighting
depression or not it's a hard thing to
go through and so if we could change
your income and say gosh get you making
thirty forty thousand dollars a year I
got a feeling that a lot of your debt
would go away and and you'd also feel a
lot better so this this really is at the
core and income crisis and a career
crisis isn't it yes okay how good a
reader are you do you do good on reading
if I send you some stuff to read well
you know I already bought a packet it
was on sale for 2495 mm-hmm there's it
gotten there yet not yeah no Italian do
you know what's in it um let me see
I haven't read her on my email this says
all right hey well let's let's skip that
here's what we're going to do a combo
with budgeting software okay all right
you need a copy of the book called start
and you need a copy of a book called 48
days
the work you love start and 48 days to
the work you love and we need to start
reading career books I'll tell you
another book you need to read is the
book I wrote
that's little-known book but it was a
New York Times bestseller called more
than enough so I'm going to put those
three in a bundle and ship them to you
and I'm also going to have Kelly pull up
your ticket and cancel the the charge so
that the stuff that's shipped to you
already is free okay because you don't
need to be buying stuff as cheap as
broke as you are you don't need to be
buying books from me I'll give them to
you okay thank you so much all right now
here's what I want you to do I want you
to read and read and read and read and
read and I don't want you watching
television I don't have it good and
how's your exercise program I don't
really have one good you need one moving
your body releases endorphins and
proteins into your life and into your
brain and it makes you feel better and
so going outside for a walk I don't have
a bike yeah that's fine just go for a
good long walk you got the California
Sun use it and let's get out there and
enjoy that and get the vitamin D on you
too that helps because I need to get you
positive and get you jacked up and
believe in you can win because it's time
for you to go win we'll help you with
this we're going to send you out some
materials you hold on the line and
Kelly's going to pick up that puts this
our the Dave Ramsey show in the books